اعترضت طائرة مقاتلة صينية من طراز j16 يوم الجمعة
طائرة تجسس أمريكية في مجال
جوي دولي فوق
بحر الصين الجنوبي ، ووصفوه بأنه
مناورة عدوانية غير ضرورية
كجزء من The Intercept ، ألق نظرة هنا ،
هذا من قمرة القيادة للطائرة الأمريكية
والصليب الأحمر.  -135 أن الطائرة المقاتلة الصينية
تنطلق إلى اليمين هناك لأنها تقطع في
الأمام بشكل أساسي شرائح
أمام الطائرة الأمريكية من
مسافة قريبة إلى حد ما وهذا الاضطراب هناك ناتج
عن اضطراب ويك قبالة الجزء الخلفي من
تلك الطائرة المقاتلة الصينية موقف الولايات المتحدة
هو  من الواضح هنا أنهم يصرون على أنهم
سيواصلون العمل في مناورة آمنة ومهنية
في أي مكان
يسمح به القانون الدولي بشكل أساسي ،
وهنا يكمن الخلاف حول
المجال الجوي للولايات المتحدة على جزء كبير من
بحر الصين الجنوبي وهو مجال جوي دولي فوق
المياه الدولية.
بحر الصين
كمياه إقليمية خاصة بها ، وبالتالي
تعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة هي الغزو الأمريكي
لموقعها الإقليمي الذي لا تعترف به الولايات المتحدة